foreign
says I'm having a hard time getting my
wife on board we have no Consumer Debt
just our house our emergency fund is
fully funded for a year we make around
three hundred and eleven thousand
dollars a year before taxes I've cut up
my credit cards but my wife doesn't want
to cut hers up she feels like she needs
them to have she needs to have them for
an emergency what can I do to get her on
board and not argue about cutting her
cards up
so I'm looking at this this is not an
issue of this is not a math problem this
is not a rational approach problem over
the years how have you seen this play
out Dave
well I mean
the answer to your question is how do I
get her on board is complicated but her
actual statement is absolute horse crap
it's incorrect yeah I mean that's just
bull you don't need a credit card for an
emergency you make 311 000 you have a
fully funded emergency fund and no debt
that's just stupid you have a double
emergency fund no but that's not exactly
how you convert her okay wouldn't go at
it that way okay honey you're stupid hey
you're just dumb no that that's uh
that's ridiculous that that one never
worked for me so um let's try a
different tack
um so the thing is this
um
I always when anytime I'm trying to get
anyone spouse included on board with
something I generally will pan back and
look further into the future
instead of like this week I'm thinking
about credit cards I'm thinking about
what are the best
things that are in our life the what has
to be true about our life that gives us
or if these things were true about our
life they give us the best probability
of being
prosperous in our marriage and
prosperous financially
so 20 years from today
if we're using credit cards as our
emergency backstop is that the most
likely way that we become prosperous or
if we got rid of them is that the most
likely way that we become prosperous
and so then that what that does is it
takes your hands off the wheel of the
moment the the the anxiety in the moment
um because what's happened here is she
remembers being broke
and so
I can tell you 30 years ago we filed
bankruptcy had our water cut off our
electricity cut off almost lost our home
uh
had a brand new baby and a toddler and
uh if I
move towards a purchase of some kind 30
years later without my wife being
involved and agreeing that the idea is
within our budget and it's not going to
destroy us then that that pattern of
behavior that body language that I do
when I do that activates it's a Memory
yeah it's a trauma response that's right
she has a trauma response to it and so
she'll go you know she'll act like we
have absolutely no money and we have
hundreds of millions of dollars right
you know it's like oh God
you know it's like whoa whoa whoa we
were buying a box of gum here it's
Costco we don't need that much
holy crap you know it's like you're out
of control and it's like she doesn't
yell like that but her body does I can
watch her do that yeah and that I those
eyes get that fire in him you know and
all that is is she just is that that it
activates that Terror down inside of her
that she felt when she was a young mom
and didn't know if her kids are gonna
have food right and so that's why your
wife's not cutting up her car it's not
because of present day circumstances but
because she remembers am I right yes and
I've also seen the more uh on on my show
here is there's a sense that
um and it's it's so far it's been
uniquely women but it may go it may go
with men too
this idea that I need to hang on to
something in case he leaves
I'm going to hang on to some sort of
something so I'm not hung out to dry
Here My Last Vestige of Independence
that's right and so I would ask Tony
something about their Dynamic at the end
of the day says she doesn't feel safe
could it be that she doesn't feel safe
what you're talking about because of
past she remembers being broke she
doesn't feel safe because there's
something about you husband who's making
a little different definition of an
emergency yeah like I I just need some
an escape hatch in case this thing goes
south yeah and so I if everything all
everything's safe
um around the board I love the idea of
hey would you commit to 30 days of
practicing can we put these in a drawer
somewhere over here let's think about
what gets us to this place we want to be
10 years from now yeah and then what are
those activities and then is there a way
we can baby let's practice baby to
practice into that and put them in the
drawer freeze them in the garage freeze
them in a block eyes use only debit
cards
um and then you go okay if we had an
emergency what could we rely on and in
the sense of being dependent are safe
like
you know after we had already were
millionaires again years later uh
Sharon's daddy sent her some money and
it wasn't a lot I mean 10 20 000 bucks
or something whatever it was nice nice
gift I mean he sent all his kids like
some money right it wasn't a wasn't life
changing but it was just a little pile
of money and she's like well what do we
do with this and I'm like well let's
just open a mutual fund in your name
that's what's got her name on it and my
name right but her name's first and that
there's something and it's like that's
her mutual fund and air quotes right
that we own right that her daddy gave us
you know and very nice little gift and
it's grown up that's many years ago it's
turned into some money you know over
time but
um to this day if you go into my foul
drawer it's like there's a little tab
Sharon's mutual fund you know and so
there's a sense of that and it's not
that we separated our finances or not
that I was worried about the legality of
it or not that she was there's none of
that it was more of an emotional this is
yours thing and it it again relax that
traumatized place in her spirit uh
that's that was legitimately try I mean
I'm not making fun of her she had every
right to be that way and so our
emergency fund now has an emergency fund
for that reason I always want to go back
to that question
um and it's becoming more and more of a
question I ask myself and my wife and my
kid in my community
if you don't feel safe none of these
things I'm going to teach you are going
to matter because your body's gonna be
off trying to make sure you don't die in
whatever weird way it's trying to do
that so how can I create safety and
there is a point when you can't hear it
you're choosing not to hear that you're
safe fine I can't I can't think about
that but man is there a way Tony yeah so
a couple of things here one is uh look
for the safety two is look long term
and then three is develop some steps of
practice
that that uh can cause her intellect to
rot into her emotions that you know you
you live okay we're living without this
oh we're living without it oh we can
live without it oh we're okay without it
and this word has been abused in our
culture but that Dave is mindfulness
that is all of a sudden she gets a
little bit her starts beating a little
bit faster I need that credit card oh no
I don't right that's just having that
feeling thinking about it and then
letting it pass because I've got a debit
card in my wallet with a Year's worth of
salary in it yeah yeah I mean I got a
debit my debit card will do everything
your credit card will do times probably
two or three right it well yeah I mean
because there's money in there right and
so I can do I can go just boss
you know subject to the Daily
limitations on the stupid thing or
whatever yeah maybe Tony maybe go get
her two debit cards from two different
banks and it's got each one of them's
got X number a thousand dollars in it
and yeah been that that's not to be
touched you know these are these are
debit cards we don't use because they're
tied to the emergency fund emergencies
and so and so they have the exact same
power
that if you wanted to drop 25 000 bucks
into credit card debt due to an
emergency instead we have 25 000 in this
account that's never going to be touched
and the debit card's in your wallet
right
how is that different mechanically it's
not right it's it's actually better yeah
so yeah you've got to offset it and um
but here you know I will tell you Tony
that that I run into a lot of marriages
too and This falls under the heading of
feeling safe or being safe
um including mine
in the early days where uh she doesn't
feel like she has an equal vote
at the budget committee meeting
and if that and so she needs to hold
this in case
uh in case you go crazy because her vote
doesn't count and so it took a it took a
while for Sharon and I to get to where
Sharon really felt her vote was equal to
mine on financial decisions and on the
budget committee meeting monthly we're
going to spend money on this because you
want to and I don't want to nope
until we come into agreement we're not
doing